boa tarde a todo mundo
bem como ela apresentou um número final
do dinheiro
eu sou do município de igarapé miri sou
o próximo do do nosso amigo aqui que é
hora de uma palestra e eu vim de lá com
esse meu trabalho que era tomado a sair
bem e atualmente mora aqui em belém já
faz alguns 10 anos aí mora no bairro da
terra firme roupa logo então é vida de
largar premiere
eu tive a honra de poder fazer uma
faculdade me formei em design gráfico e
atualmente eu comecei a desenvolver seu
trabalho que é o trabalho da turma do
açaí como começou a minha história
cheguei aqui é em belém como é como se
fosse a canoinha está com toda a família
com toda a galera no rio aí é e chegando
aqui em belém pôde conhecer um pouco não
conhecer muito a cidade também
ribeirinho né minha família ser de graça
e mirim
a gente veio pra cá meu pai conseguiu
emprego aqui e começou a trabalhar aqui
e viemos juntos nesse período é eu não
tinha muita idéia da técnica do desenho
é eu só fui aprender depois que eu
comecei na verdade eu assistia muito o
desenho não era moleque seja muito
desenha indo para a escola eu desenhar
muito no caderno minha mãe me chamava
muita atenção minha isso não dá futuro
para de ficar desenhando estuda é é eu
estudei no colégio de freira no interior
né
atualmente essa escola ainda existe
ainda tá
e esse trabalho vem junto comigo tá
a turma do açaí ela foi criada em 98
é de muito tempo as pessoas acham que
ela foi criada atualmente agora é ea
partir desse período eu trouxe
personagens comecei a estudar bastante
chegando na terra firme
eu não tinha contato com o computador
não tinha nada assim que eu pudesse ter
esse acesso
só tinha o meu lápis o meu caderno de
desenho ali para poder desenhar e
conhecer o espaço aqui em belém que se
chama o serpro que é um centro de
tecnologia
eu moro ali próximo da ufra ali a
perimetral e o cérebro ele fica alguns
três quarteirões da minha casa e nesse
período eu comecei a visitar esse espaço
claro na época sempre tem aquela lan
house é que as pessoas querem cobrar por
acesso à internet mas não tinha
conhecimento que era uma internet não
saber nem mexer ainda nem no mouse
teclado pior ainda era só na caneta e
mal e comecei a conhecer esse espaço
através de um amigo ali existe um local
aqui na terra firme que se chama certo
espaço cidadão que pode freqüentar pode
de repente lá estudar e ele sempre me
três folhas ficam as regras que eles
colocavam lá não tinha passagem de
ônibus foi andando foi roubado mais três
vezes
mas continuei a então esse eu ia sempre
lá nesse período a atingir uma uma
coordenadora lá que se pretende a gente
nessa era até ontem estava usando os
computadores ampla três computadores e
frequentava esse espaço perturbador de
ela ligava olha eu tô indo pra ir pra
aprender um pouco sobre a tecnologia
aprendi a mexer com software livre que a
tecnologia livre pra quem já deve
conhecer aí é aquele do pinguim e eu
comecei a mexer nessa tecnologia não
sabia nada nada nada mesmo é que acho
que o primeiro só comecei a a mexer foi
o linux windows só foi ter contato
depois né
e comecei a mexer com os programas que
foi o olympique seria o photoshop que
nós conhecemos proíbe o coreldraw que é
um escape do linux né e outras
ferramentas que é a questão de você
o de colorir o seu desenho então o que
eu fazia trabalhava com esse desenho e
levava com cérebros ganhava e começava a
montar eles
nesse período eu montei um blog aprendi
a mexer com um blog e tanto ali
acessando casualmente alguém olhou eu
fazendo aquilo no computador
não sei acho que foi destino né aí eu
não sabia que estava acontecendo porque
eu estava tão concentrado ali e me
chamar o casamento do século
mas o que será que fiz alguma coisa de
errada me chamar assim né
foi falar com a diretoria do século lá
eles viram meu trabalho comecei a falar
que eu tinha feito um trabalho de um
século e ouvindo meu blog e aí eu
comecei a ter esse contato com a
tecnologia é comecei a aprender a
colorir os desenhos
a ter esse contato e acho que minha
primeira palestra a diferença de
palestra foi ali no hangar que me
convidaram um grande evento de software
livre vai nesse evento que tomar seu
trabalho lá
esse mesmo mas não sei falar como é que
vou chegar lá
então quando eu cheguei lá vi muita
gente não muito mais que tem aqui né
muita gente mesmo estava muito nervoso
engraçado que tinha vários doutores ali
que onde palestrará e o nome do rosinei
rosa pinheiro tomando a sair bem no meio
eu fiquei nervoso mas é aí onde eu vou
sentar não vai sentar ali pronto comecei
a falar sobre o trabalho estava
supernervoso que a gente sempre fica
nervoso né
seja qualquer parece que isso vai passar
e daí eu comecei a ter esse contato com
as pessoas
terminou tudo aquilo ali aí eu comecei a
observar a a a imensidão daquela coisa
que minhas palavras nem do meu trabalho
não você só vai lá na frente fala sobre
seu trabalho que você faz e pronto
daí as pessoas me convidaram consigo
emprego na seduc nesse período de chamar
para trabalhar no site da seduc
fiquei um bom tempo na área de
comunicação atualizando o site da seduc
e daí eu comecei a ter vontade de poder
jogar como do açaí para dentro da seduc
que começou essa divulgação
e eu comecei a trabalhar com esses
personagens chamado a turma do açaí que
são esses aqui tá aí você deve estar
curioso que aquele debaixo do braço dele
é o bonequinho mas a ilsinho tá eu então
esse bonequinho aqui é aquele pechito
ben ali né então esse aqui a turma do
açaí a turminha pai d'égua tá então o
primeiro deles é o açaí que é o boné o
personagem principal da história tá
então trago isso tudo no interior do
município de igarapé miri porque ela é a
terra do açaí para onde você ontem uma
hora de sair é baratinho acho que no
real tentou comprá lo a sair é barato lá
muito maratá e da tem o camarão uma
parada aí o que acontece
o o personagem
o primeiro é o açaí sozinho ali né que o
personagem principal
vou falar bem rapidinho aqui pra vocês a
mariazinha que a irmã do açaí
ele é negro ele é pretinho porque
compara a questão do caroço do açaí
tá claro esse bonequinho aqui eu amo
muito ele é meu personagem predileto
neinha criação e ali temos ali a índia
em chennai iraque é uma personagem
também faz parte da turma das aí que
defende a natureza
tá então para cada personagem tem um
emblema e tem uma característica
ali é a dorinha só que o pedido da
carinhosa [ __ ] no interior
isso não é uma ofensa tá meu avô me
chamado de preto e preto não é uma
ofensa ano é um carinho que o pessoal do
interior têm com com método e ela é irmã
do açaí está aquela última linha é a
marina marina sofreu cancelamento pela
gestão do barco da embarcação e isso eu
já vi de perto tira toda aquela parte do
cabelo está no barco ali ea menina vai
tirar a água e para jogar fora o cabelo
prende se uma realidade isso
no rio da amazônia muito sério uma coisa
dessa e retrata essa questão aí temos um
personagem bem aqui em baixo que é o
bibinho ele não é japonês
ele é um traço meio indígena é uma
mistura tá que é o amigo do açaí tá irmã
irmão da marina
aqui nós temos um robozinho limpinho é o
único que não come carniça tá ele é do
ver-o-peso ele o bullying pinho está
também que o bullying pietá
o interessante do mundo sublinha a única
palavra que ele fala é pior
só isso ele sempre fala isso é pior
qualquer coisa pior tá depois disso nós
temos ali o personagem trabalhou tanto
que é um cãozinho mas a 0 naquele
peixinho do rio da amazônia que tem que
ser debulhado atrás de outra tá ali nós
temos não é seu miguel eu me guerra
isso foi baseado no avô meu que já
faleceu muito tempo o cml contava
algumas lendas
ele contava muitas histórias pra mim que
eu tenho até hoje guardada escritas que
ele escreveu é que em breve espera
publicar um livro é com essas histórias
da turma do açaí
ali nós temos e manduca que é o pai do
açaí taa seu miguel avô do açaí tá e ali
ele apanhou a sair e no final nós temos
a dona raimunda mais conhecida como dona
preta que era minha avó minha avó era
uma mulher bem no negócio bem bonitona
sabe preta
então esses aqui só os personagens da
turma do açaí tá ea partir daí mas que
esse pequeno
quem é esse pequeno é um país pequeno é
bagunceiro
ele é como um garotinho de oito anos ele
e lhe perturba mesmo entendendo o
personagem que vive aprontando
ele apronta bastante então ele ele vive
várias aventuras tanto no interior e o
cenário seria o ver-o-peso tá e ali nos
arredores da ilha do combu que é o quê
onde acontece toda essa história da
turma do açaí tá tão pensando em sair é
um personagem muito bagunceiro qualidade
desde oito anos né
e ele me perturbando a irmã dele sempre
tem uma briga entre a irmã dele tá
seguindo tá aqui deixa de populares
pequena mas aí tá porque pavulagem e 98
ele a primeira tinha dele foi essa aqui
ele usava sapato ali né ele usava sapato
essa primeira tinha eu tenho
tá e aí está ele mas o bibinho é ali o
outro em 2000 ainda aparecer que ele
está aparente neamt ah ah ah
o nome do bebê era aparente era parente
mas muito amiguinho está e depois eles
foram mudando naquela época comecei até
o com aquele contato com a pintura eu
comecei a colorida um visual melhor
depois daqui ele já começou a criar a
questão das historinhas foi modificando
e depois virar uma lacuna não viraram já
uma coisa mais aquela coisa meio pop
então ali já que já cresceram bastante
né
o personagem então teve toda essa
mudança do personagem é bom entender
essa questão do personagem porque para
entender todo o processo de criação
é não sei se alguém com um design aqui
mas sempre é a gente tem esse processo
de criação é desde o início de uma coisa
bem legal que às vezes eu penso em
questão disso é que nós devemos ser
bastante criativo no que a gente produz
né
vendo as palestras e todas as pessoas
que passaram agora aqui eu pude aprender
muita coisa que eu acho que tem que
aplicar na minha vida a última do meu
amigo também olha foi bom então eu tem
que aplicar isso é cada vez mais você
aprende mas isso eu aprendi muito
hum então é isso daqui a questão dele e
também o menino estudou netair olha
deixa de ser gazeta peru o león
olha aí olha o diploma dele ó mesmo
estudou que não pode gazetaweb estudar
então isso eu pego e coloco isso na
minha história minha né então o
personagem ele além de ser bagunceiro
mas minha mistura tá só pra lembrar um
pouquinho
siga em frente as referências que eu
tenho é aqui é do raimundo manuel sobral
tá eu não vou ler muito aqui porque
nosso tempo é curto mas para você
entender e que ele lançou alguns livros
dicionário apache b é jornalista
escritor
na época ele lançou o jornal também
trabalhava no pp que até um jornal aqui
de belém era o jornal para quem pode né
no jornal meio aí ele trabalhava nesse
jornal tá então é em 96 e 98 e 2005 a id
lançou esse livro esses livros
condicionado com o país tiver que seria
a nossa linguagem clara essa linguagem
que fala goldie hawn chamando é doida é
esta
d acho a então todas essas coisas que é
o nosso linguajar do dia a dia
o objetivo da turma do açaí é esse é
resgatar essa nossa cultura ea nossa
linguagem
vamos parar de paixão sou do interior e
já viajamos para vários lugares quando
uma dessas aí né eu gostaria de poder é
compartilhar nosso trabalho em outros
locais
então esse aqui é uma inspiração ele
lançou esses livros e é daí que eu tiro
as linguagens além de pesquisar na
internet mas minha referência ele aqui
que o jornalista é que lançou esses três
livros da ilha
aqui nós temos algumas palavras né pai
d'égua é quem conhece todo mundo fala
isso pega pega né
e aqui égua são paulo eu falei égua égua
estava chegando eles né
agora é outra coisa né a mulher do
cavalo não é mulher
então aqui era gente fizesse alguma
coisa era gente é uma das frases também
tem lá né hepatite b também aquele é o
tente como um pirão ali né
richard l aquela coisa que me chamar eu
né então é o autêntico papa chibé como
pirão mesmo tá então essas são as frases
que eu uso para me poder composto ainda
do livro e pesquisando tá aqui nós temos
algumas tirinhas que que rola na
internet a primeira liu a mãe da saída
reclamando que ele está a concluir a vai
ser assim a pequena pretendendo ato irá
aquela coisa que fica newton vai lá e
toma vai lá tá brincando brincando toma
banho e tomar banho aí tá ato irá rock
e outra bem ali né só murrinha estava de
manhã quando a sendo só murrinha então
uma preguiça então essas palavras eu uso
e colocou isso na minha tinha está a
descarregar e penoso desde que apenas
acho que ela tem uma galera pecado de
cima do telhado né ela cai bastante
tá então esse personagem fala de skype
nasceu a mãe dele lá com chinelo olha só
para dar uma pisa
então essas tirinhas elas são únicas tá
não existe um longa a gente joga lá e
posta a malaca o fashion e falar olha o
ritmo dele essa batalha quem é cabelo
pintado ok o juiz lauzinho tá mais ou
menos aí é maluco fashion chegou na
internet é foi até engraçado porque mas
não é assim rosinaldo é outra coisa mas
não é só de mandar usa sandália que me
coloquei essa tinha sido a mais de 4000
compartilhamento pessoal jogo eu joguei
na internet ele estava saiu de biela na
onda né seguindo em frente à cidade
quando passa no vestibular que foi
aquela questão do do pinduca ela o pai
mãe ou então pego essas músicas que
compõem o quadril também para mostrar
essa nossa música realidade que nós
temos é quem nunca dançou essa
musiquinha no vestibular é então
retratando isso aí
aqui nosso grande remo e paysandu né
sempre tem que falar sobre isso o
pessoal adora e nossa chuvinha que tá
caindo toural agora a hitachi chuvinha
aí né é apresentado
então essas são as tirinhas que a gente
coloca além de representar essa questão
da nossa linguagem também tenha gírias
né
e olha ai castanheira líder br tá lá em
cima
annie josé américo
tá ele é e se esse cara é uma figura
acho que todo mundo já viu ele né
eu estava passando ali na joão paulo 2º
e de repente bits subiu pra mim o
flamengo não acredito que a olheira ele
aí transformei numa tirinha né aí tá aí
aí tem 12 tem outra tinha até 2 que ele
continha de volta depois né a portugal a
sair
a entrada livre é um personagem de belém
né então além de ter essa questão da
figura da nossa linguagem retratam a
realidade do dia a dia que é a turma do
açaí
o trabalho é valorizar a nossa linguagem
pacote bem tudo bem aqui também o cinema
chibé quente vez em quando faz uma
brincadeira tá star wars hoje estão
destruindo ver-o-peso tá ali é a que
faleh gua e mano pega o beco peraí
dançando no toró tá na chuva ali então
essas aí só uma brincadeira que a gente
faz aí quando lançou este jogou lá foi
muito engraçado ali aí é fazer essas
brincadeiras também com o cinema nessa
cultura é para mostrar nossa cultura que
é tão rica e aqui é um trabalho que a
gente faz com nosso cliente mostra o
trabalho da turma do açaí para as
pessoas
tá é esse primeiro quadro aqui é já tem
agora uma pequena rádio web que seja uma
vitrine musical
a gente fala sobre essa questão da
cultura também fala sobre a questão da
criança e da educação apresenta lá agora
começam os sábados né e como choveu acho
que vai chegar um pouco atrasado e ainda
a gente visitar as escolas com o
trabalho da turma da sair às vezes nós
vamos pelo amor que nós sentimos pelo
trabalho eu gosto muito desse trabalho
não tenho um cachorro vamos lá fazer o
trabalho com as crianças têm a mesma
escola que eu já fui que estava caindo
aos pedaços mas mesmo assim a gente
conseguiu levar esse trabalho para as
pessoas aqui foi a produção do filme da
turma do açaí que foi o tema do açaí no
círio e quem quiser ver pode ir lá no
youtube ok quem quiser ver um filme
completo no youtube na página todas aí
mauricio de sousa a gente conversou
também com ele fãs de lá da toma das aí
tá nossa página
lá no facebook ok e aqui o contato
deixando pra vocês aí e eu agradeço
muito a oportunidade muito obrigado
pessoal e até de x e agradeço pela
atenção de todo mundo aí espero tenho
pensado poder passar uma mensagem para
vocês e sei que a gente lá então muito
obrigado